vous avez bien fait de tarder à me
donner la parole comme ça mon niveau
d'indignation et est monté au jeu peux
m'exprimer quand même comme cette
énergie est incertain je pète rarement
les plombs d'abord je voudrais revenir
sur la première information que vous
avez donnée à savoir que manuel macron a
été bouleversé par le cim les misérables
alors qu'est ce que montre ce film ce
film montre que dans les quartiers où
l'état a démissionné l'état s'est
absenté il n'y a plus que deux instances
de régulation il ya les trafiquants de
drogue et l'islamisme les deux pouvant
se confondre c'est le film poteau de
madame vous pensez à 3 hier la politique
corrompu parce qu'il perd le maillage du
maire les instances je parle de ce qui a
remplacé l'état la bac arrive bien après
les batailles en général mais madame
peut penser que c'est un déni que c'est
une fantasmagorie que c'est quelqu'un
qui ne connaît pas la banlieue comme
c'est quand même ce que ce film montre
bon je voudrais quand même le rappeler
celle c'est le sujet précis de ce film
c'est une chance oui peut-être mais qui
a l'air de bouleverser notre président
qui rôdent qui découvrent la banlieue je
trouve ça un peu inquiétant pour la
france alors j'ai répondu non parce que
répondre oui ça voudrait dire cautionner
le fait de vouloir brûler vif un flic à
bagnols rx faisait comment tolérer veut
dire finir ça veut dire dire oui à
tendre des pièges aux flics on allumant
des incendies en attendant qu'ils
arrivaient à leur balançant des
frigidaires duo du du 10e étage et je
regrette monsieur le commissaire que
vous ayez des tuteurs de pudeur de
gazelle parce que quand on parle avec
certains de vos confrères je pense à une
consoeur avec laquelle j'ai eu une
longue conversation elle nous écrit
qu'il ya bien des zones de non droit
c'est-à-dire vous pouvez presque pu
entrer et en tout cas les autres
services les ambulanciers les pompiers
eux ne peuvent plus entrer du tout sauf
à bénéficier d'une protection policière
complètement démesuré et moi je voudrais
dire une chose je ne minimise pas toutes
les bavures policières
elle est simplement où les violences
policières je dis simplement que dans
l'actualité récente
je suis extrêmement surpris de la
sévérité des forces de l'ordre envers
les gilet jaune par rapport à l'impunité
dont bénéficient les trafiquants de
drogue dans certaines banlieues
je trouve qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures très étrange et je voudrais vous
dire aussi que je connais beaucoup de
gens qui habitent en banlieue je suis
obligé de préciser pour la clarté du
débat qu'ils sont arabes qui se sont
même musulman et qui n'en peuvent
john règne des trafiquants et de ceux
sont eux qui appelle les flics et ce
sont eux qui supplie les flics de les
débarrasser de la racaille dont vous
êtes dans un denim vous êtes dans un
déni je sais pas vous voulez absolument
accusé ces deux trafiquants voilà enfin
les trafics juste viendrait justifier
les violences policières parce que c'est
un peu ça mais moi j'ai pas la peine
d'être sinon je dis simplement que leur
place est en prison voilà mes joueurs à
la balle tout crime impuni nous sommes
d'accord déclenché un sentiment
d'injustice
donc s'il y avait plus de sévérité
lorsque ce sont des fonctionnaires de
police qui sont impliqués dans le cas de
violences policières qui entraîne la
mort s'il y avait une sévérité est pas
une forme d'iniquité au niveau des lois
et si la justice faisait son travail de
manière juste vous accusez les émeutes a
utilisé les et maintenant j'essaie de
comprendre
je n'excuse rien j'essaie de comprendre
vous dites fait un parallèle qui est
quand même quoi il parlait des gilet
jaune aujourd'hui émeutes je suis un
gros gilet jaune il se trouve que c'est
répertoriés ya des gens comme david
dufresne qui font qu'ils font un travail
voilà on sait qu'à ton des borniers
temps de mutilés on sait qu'il ya eu des
morts de manière collatérale certes donc
avec la mort de zineb redouane le 1er
décembre dernier à marseille
la mort de steve là moi je vous parle en
fait de 7,17 noté de l'autoritarisme et
de tout sécuritaire au détriment au
détriment de la population
aujourd'hui les violences des gilet
jaune elles sont visibles parce qu'elles
sont médiatisés tout simplement il n'y a
pas eu de recension des violences
policières commises en banlieue on va
parler du fameux lanceurs de balles de
défense est ce que vous savez que depuis
1995 il est oui c'est tout le monde pour
utiliser dans les banlieues par les
policiers de la bac
il a été même utiliser enfin on l'a
testé à mantes la jolie dans quartier du
val fourré on n'a pas dénombrer le
nombre de multiples de mutiler ou des
borniers mais on a eu un récemment un
jeune qui s'appelle mamadou qui a été
touchée pour maintenir le flash-ball
jeudi suite aux émeutes je vous dis
simplement que votre vision qui a des
braves gosse qui traîne et puis des
méchants policiers qui arrive ça
correspond pas à la réalité parce qu'il
ya des quartiers entiers où ces braves
gosses sont enrôlés par des trafiquants
plus hauts placés en fait moi je les
cinq ans watson sessad ans et c'est ça
qu'on essaye de briser votre petit
confort et venaient dans ces quartiers
est ce que vous savez d'aller voir mais
je savais où j'allais chez vous parce
que vous savez où je ne parlais pas sans
savoir que vous ne connaissez pas la
mienne les vidéos je peux appeler
monsieur tanner toutes les villes de
banlieue ne sont pas ne sont pas sûres
sur le sûr ne sont pas faites sur le sur
le même le même modèle on a mantes la
jolie qui est une ssii qui est une ville
de banlieue donc banlieue ouest où on a
au sein de ces deux villes
une vraie ségrégation spatiale c'est à
dire qu on a quarante mille habitants
val fourré on a eu vingt mille habitants
au val fourré 20000 habitants centre
ville avec une omniprésence policière au
val fourré et on peut croiser quelqu'un
je viens de vous expliquer que ce soit
les gens rêvent ils appellent les
policiers parce qu'ils ont des moyens
novateurs qui décèdent vous en [ __ ] je
vous aime beaucoup ça fait de la fête
versailles est de cacher ce sont les
gens de cécité qui n'en peuvent plus
laisser arrêter d'opposer j'en ai mais
un ruisseau en amérique jeunes et
policiers nous sommes évidemment
évidemment qu'on dit pas nos gamins
matin ben écoute
il est 8h30 battue va aller cramer une
ou deux poubelles bien sûr nous non
voilà
oui et pas forcément été désigné et
sortait de la culture lecture et en
quels termes d'ide en attendant je finis
on en voit dans cosmo ben salah mais
quand quelqu'un vous contredis pas
parler pas de votre petit confort c'est
savoir à qui vous vous adressez c'est
gonflant ce truc mais c'est vraiment bon
et demandez je vous assure je parle d
lounge de là où j'ai ma vie alors ne
parlez pas là bas la saison une réalité
mais attendez de voir ja d'une
quotidienne bien moi je vous ai donc
respectée elle a besoin d'un vol
fourrure peu non mais quoi conclure un
petit pont force voilà donc c'est vrai